scientists at the EU space center in
Darmstadt Germany waited anxiously for
signs of life from the probe after
nearly three years it all came down to
this would Rosetta finally awakened from
its deep sleep then the response they've
been waiting for after nine hundred and
fifty seven days speeding through the
cosmos the EU probes sent the signal
that it was up and operating it's the
most ambitious and challenging project
ever attempted by the European Space
Agency scientists compare it to the u.s.
moon landing in 1969 I think has been
the longest hour of my life but just
went but this was the most rewarding so
far so definitely I'm very very happy
the Rosetta probe carries a lander named
feel I that will drop down to a comet
comets are believed to be pristine
remains from the formation of the solar
system about 4.6 billion years ago the
material they're made of has remained
largely unchanged since they were formed
scientists hope the mission will provide
more clues about how the solar system
came into existence
you